this video is from a tick tocker who
shared her experience of having to
confront a Karen who spit on her while
she was trying to celebrate her birthday
I'm not allowed to eat here
get out of here
I don't care
can't work her out of here
come on
[Applause]
spit on me again
okay okay
y'all
what happens when I'm asking you
I don't know what happened I didn't see
nothing no no
someone [__] around
and find out you're gonna spit a
[__]
the level
in your head you think
you're gonna spit on someone
and nothing is gonna happen
I don't want to do ageism but lady
you're mad old you can't do [__] you
can't you ain't with your crew of
Karen's you
you're gonna spit on people
to me this is what happened
someone's Pat on somebody the rest I
don't know I don't know what happened
the rest I don't know about it to me
normal life ensued
what the [__]
did you think was gonna happen that
person is not well and got exactly what
they deserve well or not well you spit
you push me it's a wrap you slap me you
hit me it's a wrap do you know that in
in prison if you spit on someone that's
a felony
but now you could where people are
violent just pittance like whoa you spat
on me and [__] are in there
shanking each other and they put spin
hop up there
you gonna spit
I'm not even gonna talk about if you
spit on me
but that to me Tuesday morning it's
nothing there there was nothing there's
no there's nothing yay yay
imagine that real quick imagine you just
put your hand in your back your neck and
someone else's saliva just
a big old loogie
and you touch it but you're like
on your skin
I'll say this
lady I get that you're old but that's
not the way you exchange survival with
somebody
maybe you ain't had nothing in a long
time I don't know what the [__] wrong
with you
but it utilize your minds oh my and then
she started giving you the licks but not
the kind you wanted let me say this you
saying you're sorry on the floor no give
a [__] no no no you're not sorry about
what you did you sorry you getting this
ass whooped yeah that's what you sorry
about are you sorry you forgot how to
tongue kiss thought it was okay to just
spit at people from afar you're hot that
person is not well I mean it's not an
excuse that is a crazy thing to do with
passing to somebody
listen if if you're gonna spin on
someone at least put your hands up no no
how you gonna spit here past it like
like and pass like it's a bite like it's
a buy
you don't even have to inject saliva if
you just even did the gesture and
there's some idea of particles going out
that's crazy that that's the thing that
yo you you hit it you hit it oh but Abba
it's an old lady
should know better you hit it she been
alive that long don't know not to spit
on people who hit it yeah I think we
need to send her a maker you even
defective you even just do the jester
bruh it's a wrap it's an old lady she
can get it
but what if she's mentally sick she's
mentally sick enough to know she says
sorry right after she knew how to play
possum and play defense to cover it up
her head she ain't lost she knew it was
a problem
if she said sorry she knew it was a
problem I don't care who it is if she
said sorry she knew it was a problem and
she knew why that person was hitting so
that person was not that crazy okay you
just so much do the gesture she can get
it she get all of it she could get
stumped I don't I do not care that is
none of my business I don't think you
guys also realize
just how many bacterias are in human
saliva that's why like if a dog bites
you or something like that's completely
different than if a human bites you like
a human bite you don't even have to
worry about the bite itself it's a
saliva sinking into your bloodstream
that's really [__] bad I don't know
where your [__] mouth has been I
don't know what you've been through you
spit out people post pandemic too
hey yo get that work my lady
[Applause]
like it's really hard to say that you
don't advocate for violence after that
but
with this with this situation I don't
even I think she got a flight
she got up
really no you gotta stop it
for what it was I think it was very
small whoa okay I think it was very
small constrained because because that
she's fat on her she got a beat down I
mean that that's probably is
proportionate if that's not what I'm
saying what I'm saying is it could have
been a whole lot worse than that you
would have done that to some other
[__] you would have been dead
my lady you would have you would have
you would of a hundred percent you got
up lightly you were able to say sorry
you were able to mouth something while
you were getting a beating spitting on
somebody such a violation my mama was
giving me some beatings I could not even
talk either
you could say Sorry God damn you got off
light yeah buddy that's one thing
punching somebody that's something else
that's that's off up out of bound off
limit flag on the play uh offside uh
traffic this everything yo that is on
Wild Thing like it's it sounds weird
because there's less damage from it
physically speaking no but just think
about
okay I want you to think about anybody
think about the appearance you care
about the most now imagine someone
pushing how would you feel now imagine
someone spat on them in front of you
there's something about spitting on
somebody that's just different
it's just different that's a that's a
whole level of disrespect
it's like somebody pulling out the and
peeing on you what
else all this to say that was wild uh
but she got what she deserved so I mean
at the end of the day things are good so
you know that all I see all I saw was
self-defense
you can't hit somebody and then just be
like uh nope nope once you start that
interaction you gotta you gotta own that
and you can't certainly spit on somebody
and try to walk away and claim yo I mean
no you started that fight
because I I understand it spitting on
someone is considered awesome so that's
all I got to say about this she should
face no charges we should give her a
medal okay for serving Street Justice
and thank you my lady that's all I got
to say anything else
no I have to go to my sales place
I had to I just had to yeah
that's crazy